eu nasci no brasil para ser uma pessoa
sucesso e é praticamente
aconteceu comigo sou branco
sou homem sou heterossexual
nascido em uma família uma família de
classe média alta e eu fui muito bem
educado com a chance de uma pessoa com
as minhas características não ter
sucesso no brasil 60 a gente olhar o
histórico do nosso país
o país foi construído a partir de
premissas que fizeram pessoas com a
minha característica ao longo de todos
esses mais de 500 anos conseguirem
buscar sucesso sempre um pouco esforço
com pouco trabalho com um pouco de
oportunidade
pessoas com essas características
buscaram sucesso e conseguiram sucesso
neste país sempre a gente vem de uma
cultura
basicamente colonialista ditatorial
elitista hierárquica a história do
brasil é tudo sobre isso
esse país foi colonizado por portugal e
aqui se criou uma estrutura em que
poucos tinham poder poucos definir o
futuro de um país de uma empresa de uma
família de uma sociedade
nós entramos mundo dentro da república
basicamente com as mesmas
características a mudança do modelo
político a mudança da forma como o
estado se organiza não mexeu em nada
nessas características
isso basicamente manteve o brasil nesse
caminho durante todo esse processo
republicano que passou por uma república
democrática que passou por uma ditadura
que passou por uma ditadura militar que
foi redemocratizado e de repente a
esperança de que tudo isso vai mudar não
aparece um país ainda elitista do ponto
de vista político do ponto de vista
econômico do ponto de vista cultural do
ponto de vista social
do ponto de vista educacional quem são
os políticos desse país são os mesmos
políticos de 100 anos atrás que formaram
seus filhos que formaram seus netos
os que a grande maioria quem são os
empresários desse país são as pessoas
que tiveram acesso a esse pequeno grupo
e que a partir dali montaram impérios
nesse país
se nós voltarmos 30 anos no tempo quando
o boa parte nós aqui estamos nascendo
muito próximo disso as oportunidades que
existiam os nossos pais dos nossos avós
é um em chamas
isso faz a gente entender porque a
maioria deles um se tornou empresário
muito pequenininho
sem grande ambição ou dois foram
trabalhar empresas e fica por 20 30 40
anos
existe uma cultura do medo no entorno
dessas pessoas
o filho entra na empresa
aceito que o chefe está falando não saia
de lá porque não existe outra
oportunidade
se você então sair do eixo rio são paulo
nunca nunca bata de frente com ninguém
na sua empresa
essa é a cultura do brasil
o problema é que isso começa a quebrar
isso começa a romper isso começa a mudar
o destino dessa nação o meu destino o
destino de vocês
o brasil passa por um processo que às
vezes ele fica escondido em discussões
que são muito técnicas ou que estão
estampadas em jornais e que dificilmente
as pessoas conseguem é é é defini la
soul ou destrinchar la de uma forma mais
simples nos últimos 20 anos nesse país
o brasil definitivamente se integrou se
integrou na cadeia logística se integrou
na cadeia financeira se integrou na
cadeia cultural se integrou na cadeia de
transferência de capital de
transferência de capital humano pelo
mundo se transcender lo na cadeia de
telecomunicações e o que que se isso
tudo quer dizer que essas questões
técnicas e questões estruturais querem
dizer quero dizer muito e querem dizer
exatamente oportunidade está na frente
de muitos de nós aqui hoje com exemplos
muito simples a gente pode entender o
que isso
tudo tem mudado o comportamento de
pessoas como eu e como vocês há 20 anos
atrás
se uma pessoa da idade de vocês tiver
essa oportunidade porque o pai tem
condição financeira de mandar para fora
do país para ir para a disney para
comemorar seus 15 anos de idade
esse processo de ir pra fora
levava três meses extremamente complexo
conseguir um passaporte extremamente
complexo conseguir um visto há 20 30
anos atrás conseguiu um visto dava frio
na barriga por medo de ser negado o
visto para a entrada nos estados unidos
conseguir comprar uma passagem aérea
então terrível teu pai e tua mãe permite
você e e consegui ficar tranqüilo porque
você estava bem era impossível não
existe um cartão de crédito praticamente
não existia cartão de crédito
internacional praticamente não existia
telefone celular não existe a
comunicação com outros países de forma
simples
isso tudo transfere um risco um medo
enorme
o pai pra mãe para o filho e essas
pessoas vivem de forma muito simples por
causa desses medos o que fazia uma
criança com 15 6 a 7 anos no colégio há
20 30 anos atrás quando encontrava um
problema nada
ele reclamava e se ninguém desce ouvidos
eles simplesmente não tinha mais o que
fazer
transportamos esses dois exemplos
extremamente simplista por dia de hoje
se qualquer um de vós qualquer um de
vocês quiser neste momento em que os
estados unidos
vocês vão tirar um passaporte em duas
semanas vocês vão tirar um visto em duas
semanas se vão comprar passagem no mesmo
dia em algum site de vocês vão embarcar
no outro dia pelos estados unidos
a percepção de mobilidade percepção de
risco é completamente diferente daquela
que lhe jovem de 20 e 30 anos atrás que
não tinham que falar num colégio hoje se
não é ouvido ele acessa uma rede social
ele deixa claro exatamente o conforto
dele e se ele tiver mérito no que está
falando é possível que ele consiga
mobilizar as pessoas e eventualmente
mudar a posição de um diretor de escola
vejo que a noção do valor
o porta voz da importância de se
expressar
ela é completamente diferente jovens na
década de 80 e 90 não tinham noção do
que era possível ser feito tão cedo
um jovem hoje tem noção do que é
possível ser feito exatamente essas
pequenas mudanças comportamentais que
são oriundos daquelas integrações que
muda completamente o que está na nossa
frente brasil foi marcado por tanto por
uma economia que em cada segmento tinha
dois três quatro cinco campeões
nacionais grandes empresas que foram
montadas a custo de muito capital de uma
família rica desse passado que a gente
falou há pouco ou montada há custo de
conexões políticas oriundas desse
passado que a gente falou há pouco essas
empresas ao longo de toda a história do
brasil
nadaram em berço esplêndido conquistaram
tudo eram donas de tudo eram senhoras do
brasil pensa na cabeça de vocês quais
eram as empresas que existiam há 15 anos
atrás em cada segmento
vocês são capazes no máximo dele está 34
empresas por segmento
esse tipo de situação que gera um monte
de problemas em especial a cultura do
comando e controle
eu entro alguém manda em mim o dia que
eu assumo eu mando na pessoa
essa é a cultura é a cultura da escola
professor mano vocês obedecem
ninguém é obrigado engaja ninguém é
obrigado a se conectar por quê porque a
nossa cultura de comando e controle
o problema que tudo isso está mudando
o problema para essas empresas no brasil
de hoje que ficaram ao longo do tempo
estáticas paradas mamutes elefantes
brancos porque o estado dava dinheiro
barato porque elas basicamente vivia
numa economia oligopolista e porque
quando necessário subir a citar hifas de
importação portanto a competição com as
empresas externas era baixo quando
necessário se criar
uma série de burocracias no entorno
dessas empresas para que um estrangeiro
tivesse muito pouco interesse em vir pra
cá
o problema é que nesse momento a
tecnologia muda completamente isso a
tecnologia tem uma beleza que é a
capacidade de superar qualquer barreira
as empresas que vocês mais tem contato
hoje enquanto os cidadãos facebook não
existia há dez quinze anos atrás o
google 10 15 anos atrás
o instagram cinco dez anos atrás e aí
fica aquela aquela pergunta mas a gente
está falando só de empresa estrangeira
ou molhar um pouco no brasil 99 não
existia cinco dez anos atrás aí food não
existia cinco dez anos atrás no bem que
existe há cinco dez anos atrás
créditos não existia cinco dez anos
atrás de pés
existe a cinco dez anos atrás eu posso
estar mais uma centena de empresas o que
essas empresas têm em comum elas têm em
comum a não ligação com aquilo que a
gente chama de velha economia essas
empresas a crescerem aparecerem
elas não são dependentes de capital elas
não são dependentes de capital político
elas não são dependentes de hierarquia
elas não são dependentes de controle de
comando e controle
elas são dependentes um único
exclusivamente de uma boa idéia de
pessoas
essas empresas que eu mencionei a pouco
só empresas que apareceram na sociedade
brasileira porque hoje com a tecnologia
e todas as integrações que eu mencionei
o acesso às ferramentas que permite você
colocar algo de pé
é literalmente acessível conseguiu hoje
um desenvolvedor programar alguma
coisinha e colocar uma idéia de pé é
fácil há 20 anos atrás
impossível pegar um avião e ir pra
europa e para a ásia e para os estados
unidos para pesquisar alguma coisa para
entender alguma coisa é fácil há 20 30
anos atrás era praticamente impossível
para uma pessoa normal comum
com isso nenhuma mudança social violenta
que a velha economia tem uma dificuldade
enorme de entender que a diversidade
quem era a mulher há 20 30 anos atrás no
brasil quem era homossexual há 20 30
anos atrás no brasil quem era o negro há
20 30 anos atrás no brasil e poderia
mencionar mais várias tribos aqui eu não
estou dizendo que cada uma dessas tribos
já atingiu aquilo que merece o respeito
que merece o espaço que merece o que
estou dizendo é que há 20 30 anos atrás
só eu tinha a possibilidade de ter
sucesso porque a economia fechada o país
era fechado os valores eram fechados e
as características eram fechadas
se você está fora de qualquer coisa
disso você não serve
você vai ser um eterno proletário
trabalhador que vai sua muito e quem
sabe um dia vai conseguir criar uma
família
essa não é a realidade hoje no brasil a
mulher no brasil apareceu apareceu com
uma força tal que o mercado consumidor
hoje olha para a mulher como a pessoa
que toma a decisão de consumo apareceu
de forma tal que hoje as empresas
entendem o valor da mulher com a gestora
tomadores de decisão que junto com um
homem entre outros
entre outras tribos contribui para o
crescimento da empresa
o homossexual que era agredido há 20
anos atrás do brasil que era excluído
marginalizado que não tinha espaço para
dentro de casa dizer pai eu sou
homossexual ele hoje faz parte do
ambiente das empresas da nova economia
existe uma clara separação entre velha e
nova economia na velha economia
o chavão é essa nova geração é
preguiçosa
essa nova geração ela
tá afim de fazer eu trabalhava muito
essa turma hoje quer ficar um ano aqui
embora e já acha que quer ser líder
dentro da empresa na nova economia essa
geração é geradora de idéias e se você
for capaz de gerar boas idéias colocar
em prática e rápida e achar uma ótima
ideia pode ser escalável então você vai
criar o próximo e food
então você vai criar próxima stone então
você vai criar a próxima de 10
então você vai criar próximo a 99 então
você vai criar uma série de outras
empresas sem necessariamente ter vindo
de uma família tradicional da economia
o problema é que essa nova economia ela
gera uma série de desafios para todos
nós
ela é combativa ela é transparente
ela demanda um nível de discussão que
nem todo mundo gosta
por isso nesse processo nessa jornada
que tanto se disse aqui o fator escolha
ele se torna primordial
há 20 30 anos atrás você não tinha opção
de escolha o que aparecia na sua frente
você tinha que a garra
hoje as pessoas têm escolha a 20 30 anos
atrás existia são paulo e rio de janeiro
hoje
recife é uma cidade pujante goiânia é
uma cidade com grande florianópolis é
uma cidade pujante
cuiabá é uma cidade pujante entre outras
há 20 30 anos atrás o brasil era o seu
destino hoje você vai fazer programas
você vai fazer intercâmbio você vai
estudar você vai trabalhar com uma
facilidade muito grande
você não é mais dependente portanto o
destino está na sua mão
as empresas no brasil da velha economia
tem tido muita dificuldade de entender
isso
olhem poti [ __ ] prática diretoria de uma
empresa da velha economia o conselho de
administração da economia
abra
qualquer informação pública dessas
empresas o homem branco casado é
transexual nascido na região sudeste do
brasil
de família de classe a ou b mercado
consumidor é heterogêneo
mas as empresas continuam homogêneas a
pergunta na frente dessas empresas é
exatamente como você vai continuar
progredindo onde as barreiras não
existem mais e qualquer um pode entrar
observe como exemplo o que está
acontecendo no mercado de adquirência no
brasil temos dois gigantes que
basicamente dominavam esse mercado rede
e cielo de forma simplista 50 e 50% de
mercado para cada um
de repente aparece uma empresa chamada
stone vindo de onde de repente aparece
uma empresa chamada pagseguro vindo de
hoje e de repente essas duas empresas
começam um mês a mês mês a mês mês a mês
mês a mês
tirar market share dessas empresas como
é possível
de repente a gente olha o sistema
financeiro os bancos ea gente vê bancos
como no bem como banco inter crescendo a
sua base de clientes crescendo
rapidamente a sua base de clientes em
agência física sem gerente sem
propaganda da rede globo sem patrocínio
de um futebol sem um monte de coisa
como é possível como é que é possível
empresas terem tudo capital tamanho
acesso poder e algumas pequenas startup
de um dia pro outro serem capazes de
ameaçar o mundo mudou as barreiras
caíram tudo é acessível hoje a pergunta
que fica pra vocês é que vocês querem
estar daqui a 20 anos
vocês querem correr o risco dessa nova
economia que é extremamente volátil que
é extremamente dinâmica que
extremamente complexa que é extremamente
ambígua
vocês querem a tranquilidade de empresas
que se trabalha muito
sem dúvida alguma mas o modelo de
negócios é o mesmo
por muito tempo a gente fala o delegado
aqui hoje negado se constrói com a
mudança a gente falou de liderança
liderança se constrói com a mudança o
que essas empresas da nova economia
estão deixando para o brasil ao fazer
empreendedorismo é um brasil diferente
é o brasil ter um sobrenome não tem
valor
é um brasil que atua opção sexual não
tem valor que o sexo não tem valor que a
tua pele não tem valor
o que tem valor é mérito cras ia palavra
até então inexistente nesse país mary
tocar a cia
quem é bom quem é crime e quem é bom que
é inteligente quem colabora quem se
comporta quem desenvolve sob mas sobe
porque têm um plano de carreira definida
a cada ano eu vou ser avaliado não idade
aqui não tem valor
maturidade tem centrado a eqüidade onde
vocês querem estar
qual é o papel de vocês enquanto
brasileiros responsáveis pela criação de
um país que de alguma forma vai se
definir nos próximos 20 30 anos e vocês
a sua geração vai ser parte trabalhar
aqui um problema de forma alguma é tão
robusto é tão digno e é tão importante
quanto agora você quer ser um
trabalhador você quer ser um
empreendedor deixando bem claro que
empreenderam é montar sua empresa
empreender é dentro eventualmente de uma
empresa tem capacidade de criar porque o
ambiente permite agora fica um alerta
muito claro para aqueles que se
apaixonarem pela nova economia que
tiverem interesse na nova economia
é preciso ser uma pessoa da nova
economia
se você é uma daquelas pessoas que
continuam trocando o whatsapp piadinha
sobre mulher barbeira sobre a loira
burra
você não faz parte só aqui você vai ser
expedido
se você é um daqueles que continua
usando alguma referência a um gay como
algo negativo porque aquela pessoa não
tem coragem logo ela é gay
você não faz parte da nova economia
se você é uma daquelas pessoas que
continua olhando para o lado e não
entendendo que é o próximo
você não faz parte da nova economia
se você continua achando que é possível
viver num mundo onde a mulher não é
idêntica você homem você não faz parte
da nova economia
se você acha que você não é machista
apesar de ter nascido num país machista
e vivido por 20 e 30 anos aqui você não
faz parte da nova economia
nós não queremos você na nova economia
nós queremos a nova economia os
brasileiros dispostos a entender o papel
da mulher dispostos a entender o papel
do homossexual disposta a entender o
papel do negro e de qualquer outra tribo
que seja diferente do padrão porque são
só pessoas diversas um ambiente diverso
que vai entender uma sociedade diversa
reflitam pensa em estar aqui ou aqui não
tem certo ou errado mas é muito
importante você encaixar o seu propósito
a sua jornada o seu objetivo no mundo
que realmente está ligada a você
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]